محاوله قانونيه جديده تتوافق كما تقول
حكومه البريطانيه مع التزامات القانون
الدولي هدفها وقف تدفق المهاجرين غير
القانونيين تشريع جديد لحكومه يعطي
صلاحيات اوسعه لوزيره الداخليه البريطانيه
بشكل غير قانوني مرورا بعدم النظر في طلب
لجؤه وصولا الى ابعاده بسرعه ومنعه من
دخول البلاد في المستقبل
لن يتوقف المهاجرون عن القدوم الى بلدنا
حتى يعرف العالم ان كل من يدخل بريطانيا
بشكل غير قانوني سيتم احتجازه واعادته
بسرعه الى بلده اذا كان امنا او الى دوله
ثالثه امنه مثل رواندا وهذا بالضبط ما
سيفعله هذا القانون لوقف القوارب
القانون الجديد يسمح باحتجاز الوافدين غير
القانونيين ل 28 يوما دون امكانيه الافراج
عنهم بكفاله او مراجعه قضائيه حتى يرحل
الى خارج البلاد لكن الخطه اثارت حفيظه
المنظمات الحقوقيه المعنيه ووصفتها بغير
الانسانيه كما لم تحظى بتاييد احزاب
المعارضه التي اعتبرتها غير فعاله ما لم
تتفاوض الحكومه مع دول مثل فرنسا
ما المختلف هذه المره ليس للحكومه اي
اتفاقيات سريه لاعاده المهاجرين وحتى اذا
استمرت في عدد المرحلين لا يتعدى بضع مئات
من الاشخاص اذا ما الذي سيحدث لتسعه
وتسعين في المئه من المهاجرين الاخرين
بموجب هذا القانون
وبحسب وزاره الداخليه فان 85 الف مهاجر
وصلوا بريطانيا بطرق غير قانونيه منذ 2018
منهم 45,000 طالب لجوء ويكلفون دافع
الضرائب سته ملايين جنيه يوميا لاوائهم في
الفنادق رغم الانتقادات الواسعه لخطه وقف
قوارب المهاجرين غير النظاميين الى
الاراضي البريطانيه تبدو حكومه ريسسوناك
مصره على المضي قدما في تنفيذ احدى
اولوياته الخمسه التي تعهد بها هكذا تترك
للنخب الحكم عليها على مدى قدرتها على
الوفاء بها قبل الانتخابات العامه المقبله
مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن